as the corona virus pandemic has been
occurring we've been seeing less and
less doctors offices open and more and
more people have to go use telemedicine
instead a lot of Americans they know
about telemedicine but they don't really
sure how to access it and that's where
good rx comes in good Rx is a health
startup it's a unicorn they're valued at
more than two billion dollars and what
they do is they provide drug comparisons
and they also provide these discount
coupons for a lot of different
medications and then get them at a
cheaper price if your insurance doesn't
cover the drug last year in September
they bought a telemedicine company
called hey doctor they've created this
marketplace where you can compare
different telemedicine companies
including their own and they have this
coronavirus assessment so that if you're
feeling symptoms of coronavirus you
don't have to go into the emergency room
where you could potentially infect other
people or infect doctors and you can get
an evaluation from a doctor from your
home today I interviewed the CEO Doug
Hirsch and we spoke about how good our X
is increasing its telemedicine services
and why he thinks that hopefully
telemedicine won't go away after this
pandemic is over tell me a little bit
about this surgery guys have been
experiencing through to this coronavirus
pandemic
yeah so we are seeing a tremendous
amount of folks who are coming to good
rx to learn more about coronavirus for
many folks it's not appropriate to go
directly to the hospital if you have
mild symptoms and and so we actually you
fill out a questionnaire a medical
professional reviews it and then helps
and there may be an ongoing conversation
if there's additional symptoms or
questions with the goal of saying hey
you should actually you know go into a
medical facility or you should just stay
home and ride it out which fortunately
for many people I think it's a more mild
experience and you guys bought your own
telemedicine company last year right in
September we're trying to unravel the
the sort of mystery around telemedicine
I think the average American still
doesn't quite get it isn't quite sure
what they would use it for I think
you're seeing again some usage for like
elective things like you know for
wrecked-tile dysfunction or or Latisse
for your eyebrows or things like that
and then you have a little bit of
progress in the urgent care space
for example you know one of our bigger
categories is UTIs where you kind of
know what you need but you need to get
an antibiotic and again you don't have
that you don't have the luxury of time
and are you seeing like a significant
uptick in patients we are we are and you
know the other area that we're seeing an
uptick both on the chronovisor side but
also with all the other medical related
needs that people just aren't don't want
to go to a doctor's office right now I'm
actually very worried that a lot of
medical professionals are struggling
right now because people who do the
basic preventive medicine you know
patients are cancelling and hospitals
are cancelling and you know my few
friends here in Los Angeles are saying
the hospitals are actually quite empty
right now because they've canceled all
elective surgeries and we want to make
sure that doctors actually have an
income and can and can practice their
their business and so many of my doctor
friends have called me all of a sudden
been like oh my god I got to figure out
this time and something right now or I'm
gonna be out of business and we're going
get help by giving them the tools and at
the same point help also help you know
patients by being able to get to the
doctor when they need to
how is good our exterior as a company
right now I mean we're in kind of really
uncertain economic times have you guys
had to lay off anybody or furlough
employees um we have not we are
fortunate in the sense that you know
we're in health care and health care is
obviously something that is front center
for everybody right now we are I would
say we're really doubling down right now
in terms of trying to just let Americans
know that there are ways that they could
still get the health care they need I'm
most worried about the millions of
Americans that are being laid off and
are getting a disruption in their
insurance and that is our sweet spot in
terms of being able to help people who
you know I lost my insurance Cobra is
too expensive I can't get to the
pharmacy I can't get to a doctor I mean
we just keep focusing on those core
problems and I think it's challenging
the world that were in right now but for
us you know this is this is what we do
and and there is a lot of opportunity
for us to help more people so we
continue to just do what we do yeah can
people still use telemedicine if they
don't have insurance yes in fact the hey
doctor product that we talked about
already the majority of our doctor
visits are $20 cash there's no insurance
there's no we don't take insurance we
don't need insurance our goal is to get
to a point where both
medicine and doctor visits are such a
low cost that you don't need insurance
do you think that we're gonna see a
shift after the spin Demick is over two
more people using it just in general or
do you think that once the doctor's
office has opened back up people are
gonna go back to using their primary
care physician going in for their
appointments stuff like that we are
seeing a bit of a shift you know I look
around at my own parents and relatives
who you know suddenly out of nowhere are
using zoom and you know are able to do
teleconferencing and things that they I
always thought by beep challenging for
them and yet they've totally figured it
out
and so I feel like the more comfort
people have with these tools and the
ability to talk to someone on their
computer or you know be able to engage
in services they haven't tried before in
the circular is good I mean he goes that
saying that that Millennials and I'd say
folks whatever twenties and thirties so
many of them don't have a regular
relationship with a physician anyway I
think I saw stat recently about half of
Millennials have a primary care doctor
so these these folks are ripe for using
these types of services because they
tend to like sort of a la carte medicine
where they have a specific issue and so
I think the younger generation is ready
to go and and it's starting to use these
services but the folks who need the most
health care I think we're starting to
see a shift there just because they have
to if they want to see the doctor in
what is this April 2020 you looks like
they need to use telemedicine then most
the physicians I know are basically
saying the patient's I'm not letting you
come in my office so you need to tell
medicine unless there's a reason so
they're kind of being forced to what
they like it or not
you